qui vit dans cette partie des îles Salomon,
mais ce sont des gens qui ont été déplacés des îles Phœnix,
dans les années 60.
La sécheresse était sévère
et ils ne pouvaient pas continuer à vivre sur l'île.
On les a donc relogés ici, aux îles Salomon.
Rencontrer ces gens hier a donc été très intéressant.
Ils ne savaient pas du tout qui j'étais.
Quelques-uns m'ont reconnu plus tard,
mais je crois qu'ils étaient très heureux.
Plus tard, ils voulaient avoir l'occasion de m'accueillir de manière formelle.
Mais ce que j'ai vu hier était très intéressant,
parce qu'ici, je vois notre peuple.
J'ai parlé dans notre langue, et bien sûr, ils ont répondu,
mais leur accent —
ils commencent à ne plus pouvoir parler le Kiribati correctement.
J'ai vu cette femme avec les dents rouges.
Elle mâchait des noix de bétel,
et ce n'est pas une pratique des Kiribati.
On ne mâche pas de noix de bétel.
J'ai aussi rencontré une famille qui s'était mariée avec des locaux,
et c'est ce qui se passe.
Quand nous entrons dans une autre communauté,
des changements sont à prévoir.
Une certaine perte d'identité est inévitable,
et c'est ce à quoi nous nous attendons dans le futur
si nous migrons un jour.
CA : Ça a dû être une journée extraordinairement touchante,
à cause de ces questions sur l'identité,
de la joie de vous voir
et peut-être la réalisation de ce qu'ils ont perdu.
C'est inspirant de vous voir vous battre jusqu'à la fin,
pour essayer de maintenir la nation à sa place.
AT : C'est notre souhait.
Personne ne veut jamais quitter sa maison,
et ça a été une décision très difficile pour moi.
En tant que leader, on ne prévoit pas de quitter son île, sa maison,
et on m'a demandé à plusieurs reprises : « Comment vous sentez-vous ? »
Et je ne me sens pas bien du tout.
C'est émotionnel, et j'ai essayé de vivre avec.
Je sais que parfois, on m'accuse de ne pas essayer de régler le problème,
parce que je ne peux pas régler le problème.
C'est quelque chose qui doit être fait collectivement.
Le changement climatique est un phénomène mondial,
et ainsi que je l'ai souvent dit,
malheureusement, les pays, lorsque nous venons aux Nations-Unies —
j'étais dans une réunion avec les pays du forum des îles du Pacifique,
dont l'Australie et la Nouvelle-Zélande sont membres,
et nous nous sommes disputés.
Ça a fait un peu de bruit dans les actualités,
parce qu'ils soutenaient que réduire les émissions
serait quelque chose d'impossible à faire
parce que ça affecterait leurs industries.
Et je disais,
d'accord, j'entends ce que vous dites,
je vous comprends,
mais essayez aussi de comprendre ce que je dis,
parce que si vous ne réduisez pas vos émissions,
c'est notre survie qui est en jeu.
Il est donc question pour vous de mesurer ces questions morales.
C'est l'industrie en opposition à la survie d'un peuple.
CA : Je vous ai demandé hier ce qui vous mettait en colère,
et vous avez dit : « Je ne suis pas en colère », avant de faire une pause.
Je crois que ça vous a mis en colère.
AT : Je vous renvoie à ma déclaration précédente aux Nations-Unies.
J'étais très en colère, très frustré, et puis déprimé.
J'avais ce sentiment de futilité
de mener une bataille que nous n'avons aucune chance de gagner.
J'ai dû m'y prendre différemment.
Il m'a fallu devenir plus raisonnable
car je croyais que les gens écouteraient quelqu'un de rationnel,
mais je reste radicalement rationnel, quoi que ça veuille dire.
(Rires)
CA : Le cœur de votre identité nationale est la pêche.
Presque tout le monde est lié à la pêche d'une manière ou d'une autre.
AT : Eh bien, nous mangeons du poisson tous les jours,
et il n'y a pas de doute que notre taux de consommation de poisson
est peut-être le plus élevé du monde.
Nous n'avons pas beaucoup de bétail,
donc nous dépendons du poisson.
CA : Vous dépendez du poisson, à la fois au niveau local
et pour les revenus du pays
venant de l'industrie mondiale de la pêche au thon.
Pourtant, il y a quelques années, vous avez pris une mesure radicale.
Pouvez-nous nous en parler ?
Je crois que quelque chose est arrivé ici-même, aux îles Phœnix.
AT : Laissez-moi vous éclaircir sur l'importance du poisson chez nous.
Nous avons l'une des industries de pêche au thon les plus importantes au monde.
Dans le Pacifique, nous possédons quelque chose comme 60%
des dernières industries de pêche au thon.
La pêche est relativement sans danger pour certaines espèces,
mais pas pour toutes.
Les Kiribati sont l'un des trois propriétaires majeurs de ressources,
les propriétaires de ressources en thon.
Et en ce moment, nous recevons 80 à 90% de nos revenus
des droits d'accès et des droits de licence.
CA : De votre revenu national.
AT : Le revenu national,
qui redistribue toute notre activité
vers les gouvernements, les hôpitaux, les écoles et que sais-je.
Mais nous avons décidé de fermer cette source de revenu,
et ce fut une décision très difficile.
Je peux vous assurer que politiquement et localement, ça n'a pas été facile,
mais j'étais convaincu que c'était nécessaire
afin de garantir la durabilité de l'industrie de la pêche.
Certains éléments nous ont indiqué que certaines espèces,
en particulier le thon obèse, étaient gravement menacées.
Le thon albacore était aussi soumis à un effort de pêche important.
Le thon listao reste en bonne santé.
Il nous fallait faire quelque chose comme ça,
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai fait ça.
L'autre raison derrière cette décision
est parce que j'avais demandé à la communauté internationale
que notre lutte contre le changement climatique
devait impliquer sacrifice et engagement.
En demandant un sacrifice de la part de la communauté internationale,
je pensais que nous devions nous-mêmes faire ce sacrifice.
Et donc nous avons fait ce sacrifice.
Renoncer à la pêche industrielle
dans la zone protégée des îles Phœnix
signifiait une perte de revenus.
Cette perte est toujours en cours d'estimation,
car nous n'y avons renoncé qu'au début de cette année.
Nous verrons donc à la fin de l'année
ce que cette décision signifie en terme de perte de revenus.
CA : Il y a tant d'éléments qui en découlent.
Cette décision pourrait encourager des pratiques de pêche plus saines.
Je veux dire, de combien pouvez-vous augmenter le prix
que vous fixez pour les zones restantes ?
AT : Les négociations ont été très difficiles,
mais nous avons réussi à augmenter le coût d'une journée de pêche.
Pour chaque bateau qui vient pêcher pour la journée,
nous avons augmenté le prix — il était de 6 000 et 8 000 dollars,
maintenant il est de 10 000, 12 000 dollars par jour de pêche.
C'est une augmentation importante.
En même temps, il est important de constater
que dans le passé, ces bateaux de pêche
capturaient peut-être 10 tonnes par jour.
Ils capturent désormais 100 tonnes parce qu'ils sont devenus si efficaces.
Nous devons donc réagir de même.
Nous devons faire très, très attention car la technologie s'est tant améliorée.
Il fut un temps où la flotte brésilienne se déplaça de l'Atlantique au Pacifique.
C'était impossible.
Ils commencèrent à expérimenter pour savoir si c'était possible.
Ils ont maintenant des façons de le faire, et ils sont devenus si efficaces.
CA : Comment se déroulent ces négociations ?
Vous êtes contre des entreprises
qui ont des centaines de millions de dollars en jeu, essentiellement :
comment tenez-vous le coup ?
Y a-t-il un conseil que vous pouvez donner
aux autres dirigeants qui font face à ces mêmes entreprises
sur la façon d'obtenir le meilleur pour votre pays,
d'obtenir le meilleur pour le poisson ?
Quel conseil donneriez-vous ?
AT : À mon avis, nous accordons trop d'importance aux licences
afin de recevoir un taux de rendement.
Le retour sur les droits de licence
est d'environ 10% de la valeur au débarquement de la capture
sur le ponton, pas dans le commerce.
Et nous ne recevons qu'environ 10%.
Au fil des ans, nous avons essayé
d'augmenter notre participation dans l'industrie,
dans la capture, la transformation,
et enfin, je l'espère, le marketing.
Ces marchés sont difficiles à pénétrer,
mais nous travaillons dans cette direction.
Et oui, la réponse serait d'améliorer l'offre.
Afin d'augmenter notre taux de rendement, notre implication doit aussi augmenter.
C'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire,
et l'industrie doit être restructurée.
Nous devons dire à ces gens que le monde a changé.
Nous voulons maintenant produire le poisson nous-mêmes.
CA : Pendant ce temps, vos pêcheurs locaux
peuvent toujours pêcher,
mais comment vont les affaires pour eux ?
Est-ce plus dur ? Est-ce que les eaux se vident ?
Ou est-ce conduit d'une façon durable ?
AT : Pour la pêche artisanale,
nous ne participons pas à l'activité de pêche industrielle,
à part seulement pour fournir le marché local.
L'industrie du thon concerne entièrement le marché international,
principalement ici aux États-Unis, en Europe et au Japon.
Je suis un pêcheur, un vrai de vrai,
et jadis, je pouvais pêcher du thon albacore.
Il est maintenant très rare d'attraper un thon albacore,
parce qu'ils sont extraits de l'eau par les centaines de tonnes
par ces navires à senne coulissante.
CA : Voici quelques jolies filles de votre pays.
Je veux dire, lorsque vous songez à leur futur,
quel message avez-vous pour elles
et quel message avez-vous pour le monde ?
AT : Je n'arrête pas de dire au monde qu'il faut vraiment faire quelque chose
sur le changement climatique,
parce que c'est le futur de ces enfants qui compte.
J'ai 12 petits-enfants, au moins.
Je crois que j'en ai 12, c'est ma femme qui sait.
(Rires)
Et je crois que j'ai huit enfants.
C'est leur futur qui compte.
Chaque jour, je vois mes petits-enfants, du même âge que ces jeunes filles,
et je me pose des questions,
et je me mets parfois en colère, ça m'arrive.
Je me demande ce qu'ils vont devenir.
C'est donc pour eux
que nous devrions dire à tout le monde
que leur propre intérêt n'est pas la question,
parce que, malheureusement, le changement climatique,
est considéré par beaucoup de pays comme un problème national.
C'est faux.
C'est le sujet de la dispute récente
entre nos partenaires australiens et néo-zélandais et nous,
parce qu'ils ont dit : « On ne peut plus réduire. »
C'est ce que le chef du gouvernement australien a dit :
nous avons fait notre part, nous réduisons les émissions.
J'ai dit : « Et le reste ? Pourquoi vous ne les gardez pas ?
Si vous pouviez garder le reste de vos émissions
à l'intérieur de vos frontières,
nous n'aurions pas de questions.
Vous pourriez faire ce que vous voulez.
Mais malheureusement, vous nous les envoyez,
et le futur de nos enfants en est affecté.
C'est vraiment le cœur du problème du changement climatique de nos jours.
Nous allons nous retrouver à Paris à la fin de l'année,
mais à moins que nous ne le considérions comme un phénomène mondial,
parce que nous le créons, individuellement, en tant que nations,
mais ça affecte tout le monde,
et pourtant nous refusons de faire quoi que ce soit.
Nous faisons face à la situation à un niveau national,
mais c'est une erreur — le problème est mondial,
et il doit être abordé collectivement.
CA : Les gens ont beaucoup de difficultés à réagir aux graphiques et aux nombres,
et nous fermons les yeux.
Mais lorsqu'il s'agit des gens, nous réagissons parfois un peu mieux.
Il semble très plausible que votre nation,
malgré, ou plutôt à cause des problèmes majeurs auxquels vous faites face,
devienne le signal d'alarme pour le reste du monde qui brille le plus visiblement,
le plus fort.
Je veux vous remercier de notre part à tous
pour l'exemple extraordinaire que vous montrez et pour être là.
M. le Président, merci beaucoup.
AT : Merci.
(Applaudissements)